i personally think that it is
embarrassing more than embarrassing it
is simply wrong
for us to be the only country in the g7
nations around that table that's
actually cutting our aid budget
at a time like this i think that of
course we have to be doing more work in
relation to vaccines
and we should be starting with a bit of
international leadership which is
how do we make sure that we increase the
amount of vaccine that's available
but that is that is just not the same
issue as ensuring that we continue to
invest in the poorest countries
and allow them to lift themselves up at
a time like this
with this pandemic for example it is
obvious that the
health systems of many countries are
simply not up to an adequate
when it comes to being able to give out
the vaccine even if it was available
so it shows once more how important it
is that we continue to do
the right thing and invest in in
international aid
do you think that um you heard the prime
minister talk yesterday
about building back uh in a gender
neutral way in a
more feminine way um do you agree with
that
and do you think that uh they this is
what they're putting forward is a way
of achieving that
i don't really understand what he's
talking about to be honest with you i
think what we should be doing is of
course we should be building back in a
way which is better we should be much
more
aware of the threat of climate change
that is the single biggest threat that
we face
and i think that when people look back
on this g7 they will be looking at it
and thinking
the optics were great cornwall has never
looked better with brilliant having a
different type of
president coming over you know so much
was going the right way but did we
really
use it as much as we could have to what
extent is this a wasted opportunity
so did we do enough in relation to
vaccines did we actually get some action
to increase the amount of supply did we
really step up in the way that we must
do
as attenborough has been warning us this
morning to be able to step up and do
something
about climate change adequately not just
talking about what we can do with our
own countries
but actually how are we what are we
going to do internationally what are we
going to do
about ensuring that we that the
corporations finally pay the right
amount of tax
and frankly they're not and even this
agreement is frankly meager
compared to what it could be so i think
g7 could have been so much more now is
that feminine is that masculine i don't
really care
to be honest with you trevor what i care
about is climate change i care about
making sure we've got vaccines that i
make and i
care about corporations paying their way
the pro
oh forgive me there's a delay here so
i'm slightly missing
what you're saying but that's okay but
um are you
supportive of the prime minister's one
billion
jabs target
i kind of feel as though it's missing
the point i think that
you know if we say you know we will hand
over our spare vaccines that isn't
really
the issue is something else yeah the
issue is that we
as as a globe are not making enough
vaccine
we don't have enough factories around
the world strategically placed
making enough vaccines and being able to
step up and increase production
in the end otherwise if we don't do that
then we will continue to be saying
oh should this group have it should that
group have it have we handed over enough
we need to make sure that we are
producing enough as a world
so that when we are all talking about we
may i hope we don't but we may in the
autumn be talking about the need for
top-ups and all of us to have top-ups
we may i hate to say in five years time
be talking about another pandemic
one thing we know is that we weren't
prepared as a world
for this pandemic we need to make sure
that we have
a strategy agreed internationally on
what it is that we're going to do next
not just talking about how much do we
have to spare that we can share with
others
that really isn't addressing the
fundamental problem
labor in the end accepted the northern
ireland
protocol um
where do you think we've got to in this
summit uh
the uh prime minister island this
morning told
sky news that he thought that there is a
practical arrangement available
but um the government is saying that the
eu
is being overly bureaucratic do you buy
that
i think we just need to get this sorted
out i think it's completely ridiculous
i think that there are plenty of ways it
can be sorted out and the government
needs to step up and do it many things
have been suggested to it
and we need to have a veterinary
agreement with the eu we don't have one
at the moment
i personally think that the swiss model
is probably the best one that we should
have
we should just get on with it we should
we should understand that when we sign
up to international agreements
they are legally binding documents and
they need to be taken seriously
and we have to find a pragmatic way
through this i'm not saying
that the european union isn't being
petty i'm not saying that the number of
stops on the border
are frankly ridiculous but they are
sticking within the letter of the law
and we need to find a solution to that
and solutions are available
we just need to step back take a deep
breath and look beyond the sausages
and think you know what is the policy
that needs to be fixed and there are
plenty of things out there
and as i say a veterinary agreement
along the lines that the swiss had with
the
european union seems to me to be a
solution but there are plenty of others
you know a whole panoply of different
things for them to pick they just need
to get on with it
emily thornberry though isn't this the
remainer
in you speaking essentially saying well
look
you know it's all a bit difficult but if
the eu really
want to bear down we don't want to have
a fight we just have to be a rule taker
in this situation
now look the united states has a better
veterinary agreement with the european
union than we do we don't have one
we don't have an agreement as to what
food needs to cross the border and i'll
tell you why
it's because the government wants to
have as much flexibility as possible
when it comes to potential other trade
deals so they want to
have the potential to lower our farm
standards and our food standards
in order to be able to accommodate other
future trade deals
frankly i think they have got this
completely the wrong way around what we
should be doing
is looking at what is in britain's
interests they have always said that
they will not
lower our food and farming standards
beyond below that
that there is in the european union so
if that's right why can't we just agree
that with the european union
because they want to keep their options
open and they want in future
to have the potential to lower food
standards
particularly because they're after a
trade deal with the united states
and the irony is here we have the united
states president
saying do you know what the most
important thing is not a trade deal
between britain and the united states
the most important thing
is the good friday agreement and we in
america are prioritizing that and we
think that you and britain should be
doing that too
and i agree big choice tomorrow big
choice tomorrow june
the 21st should we
lift the restrictions given that
actually
a lot of countries vaccinated um the
businesses are crying out or are you
leaning now towards
caution on the labor side
i'm so sorry i didn't hear that question
trevor do you mind asking it again
i uh no problem i was asking you
we have this big decision about june the
21st where is labour standing now
do you say that we should go ahead lift
the restrictions
free businesses who are crying out and
so on
or are you now inclined given the data
towards caution
we have always been inclined towards
more than inclined we have always said
that we must follow the scientific
advice and the scientific advice
is pretty clear that we can't have
a uh lifting of a lockdown at the moment
there needs to be
more of a delay because of the variant
and because of all the other reasons
i just want to be confident that the
prime minister is listening to that
scientific agreement
you know you do look back and wonder
whether you know now you wonder
what on earth were they did they think
they were doing by not closing the
borders at the time when they should
have
i have no doubt there was no scientific
advice
telling them not to close the borders
because they should have particularly
when the delta variant
started and you know you wonder why it
was that they kept the border open for
example with india
and yet closed the border with pakistan
and bangladesh
i think it was because boris johnson
continued with the fantasy that he was
going to be
right until the last minute that he was
going to be allowed to go to india
and and sign some sort of pre-trade deal
it's another example of putting trade
deals and
standing in front of flags and signing
them up and and and so on
before the interests of our country
trade deals ought to be
about what are the interests of our in
our country and make sure our trade
deals reflect that
and build on it not the other way around